let's practice boy true vien arms so
important and for a bunch of reasons
face this way with me pal nice view I
hope you have a nice view like this take
your right arm point out here you let it
draw pass the legs so it swings up to
the nose pass the ear to back the head
reach and it drops again so if I turn
I'm mirroring you so check your posture
right bounce a little bit
it's your spine tall as your heart open
a little bit okay gently just it's a
feeling of expansion not jamming your
shoulders back just letting your heart
expand okay stay right arm it's swoops
past the legs and notice if you really
relax it'll circle to your notes you
don't need to go like this it'll just
circle and make an arc to your notes
then it goes around past your ear to the
back of the head then gently reach the
arm up and relax around reach relaxed
reach relaxed reach your other arm your
left arm it drops faster legs circles to
the nose smack the head now if you get
to the bottom that you cut up you'll go
over the top your head which we don't
want right now so if you have this habit
you'll also have this habit and I want
you to let it circle so when it gets
tree nose it's going this way then it'll
travel past your ear and up scoot around
ear and up you want to be able to are
you listening and around like you've got
a shell and you're listening to the show
come back your right hand again now
you're gonna start here it's gonna go up
it goes up and drops it back of the head
now when you do that we don't want to do
this you don't want to pop your shoulder
out of the socket your shoulders your
your shoulder blade your shoulders
relaxed it's extending through the arm
but not doing this so close up drop the
back head and if you relax it's gonna
come pass the air past the notes in
circles past the legs and starts again
the head and make sure also here you
don't cut the corner you want to let it
get right up to the imaginary battle
above your head and then the back of the
head all the way up left arm up it goes
to back the head up it goes to back the
head now again your posture if you let
your posture go at all it's gonna be
it's gonna go more like this which isn't
so elegant if you stand tall your hearts
expanding your hand will naturally go to
the back your head so it's a good way to
check your posture if it lands at the
back of the head that means you've got
your posture very tall if it takes a lot
of effort it probably means you're
slouching when both they're working
we're gonna put them together so we can
face this way together and we're gonna
pick that the left is gonna go up the
right it's gonna go down to the left
it's gonna go to the back of the head
pow and the hands get to the head
together both hands go around past the
ears and then you just expand the right
can't go down to the right has to go up
and they circle and the left goes to the
back the head and around and expand
around
expand now you might snap when you're in
this position guess this is a quick true
viewing position left is up right it's
down to the head around and open to the
head around and open now there's a lot
going on here there as you can check
that you every time you gets here you're
in a perfect key you're not here you
don't want to do this you want to end up
in that tight ruthian position and the
hands get to the head together around
open together plate rubian to the head
together around open so it's going to
take practice you can go the other way
right up left down then right get to the
back of the head around and open the
right gets to the back head around and
open right to the back around and open
right the back around and open so this
week just make sure you can circle
either way it's really good to build it
up from the ground one arm at a time to
make sure you've got you're getting some
good habits to the body and as it begins
to flow what we're gonna do is we're
learning how to turn with all of this
you know to play trivia into extension
and then we're going to learn how it all
becomes PI mu Vincent poi turns but we
probably won't be doing it standing out
a lot
[Music]